qué significa la llegada de los
talibanes a kabul y su eventual retorno
al poder después de 20 años
bueno yo creo que significa el fracaso
de la política exterior norteamericana
en afganistán
ha representado incluso el fracaso en
aquellos momentos de la guerra fría de
la unión soviética hoy lo es de eeuu y
sobre todo pues por el desgarrador el
enfoque que hay por ejemplo del
desempleo de un 12 por ciento ciudades
totalmente divididas y ahora el regreso
de una fuerza de un poder fáctico que ha
estado prácticamente dominando pues
algunas provincias desde hace años y
ahora pues también aprovechando el vacío
institucional
yo creo que básicamente lo que estamos
viendo ahora es el fracaso de una
estrategia que gastó aproximadamente
700 mil millones de dólares la
administración estadounidense desde el
año 2001 hasta lo que se tenía reportado
en el 2019 cosa que pues hizo muy
felices a los principales
corporativos armamentistas de eeuu y
algunos de europa pero muy poco a los
ciudadanos y ciudadanas afganas
a este fracaso al que usted se refiere
puede deberse el hecho de que el
gobierno afgano esté facilitando una
transición del poder luego de que había
prometido frenar los avances de los
talibanes
yo creo que el gobierno afgano siempre
tuvo debilidades precisamente porque los
animales nunca dejaron de controlar
rutas estratégicas para el tráfico de
opio por ejemplo en los talibanes nunca
dejaron de tener armas necesarias para
poder defender esos territorios y pues
lamentablemente para mí no para mal el
gobierno afgano pues careció de
estrategias eficaces para irse volando
pues ese poderío que los talibanes nunca
dejaron creo que el base institucional
que tenemos ahora también tiene que ver
con el interés que tiene afganistán para
otras potencias que ahora también están
preocupadas china india irán por ejemplo
son países que van a estar ahora muy
alertas para evitar que afganistán caiga
en un caos
me parece que lo mejor para los países
que rodean las fronteras de afganistán
ahora es que afganistán no caiga en una
guerra civil sino que como bien se ha
comentado por parte del gobierno afgano
pues la transición se puede hacerlo más
pacífico posible debido a que un
escenario de guerra civil será
catastrófico pues no solamente para los
países -insisto aledaños sino también
para la propia población acan doctor
garduño la comunidad internacional ya
avanza en la evacuación de sus
connacionales en afganistán están
dejando solo al país
no no está dejando solo lo que pasa es
que la evacuación se tenía planificada
para unos seis meses pero no se contaba
con el avance tan rápido que están
teniendo los talibanes de hecho han
venido a sacudir esos planes de
evacuación y ahora no se han tomado las
medidas necesarias para acelerar eso más
que por el envío de cinco mil tropas más
por parte de eeuu y alguna algunos
esfuerzos de corte el negociador en doha
estoy en qatar pero me parece que no es
que lo hayan dejado solo sino que la
estrategia ha sido fallida de igual
forma lo fue en irak por ejemplo también
que fue un país que se invadió dos años
después de haber entrado a afganistán y
también ha sido fallida en otros casos
de ayuda como lo estamos viendo por
ejemplo ahora mismo en líbano también
donde ahora no hay combustible para la
población de ese país no entonces ha
sido algo sistemático que tenemos que
aprender también a dar fórmulas más allá
del armamentismo sobre todo el
desarrollo y de bienestar institucional
ahora hay reportes de ciudadanos
intentando ir desesperados del país
hacia sus vecinos inmediatos como
pakistán por ejemplo hasta dónde va a
llegar esta crisis humanitaria
esto es algo que nos puede dar pistas de
la situación humanitaria en caso de que
no haya esta transición pacífica de la
cual hablamos países como irán también
están recibiendo muchísima población de
corte en hasaba de corte incluso también
pasto que pues puede ser población se
podría pensar cercana a los talibanes
pero que como estamos viendo pues están
saliendo del país yo creo que lo que
buscan estas personas que están saliendo
mucho ojo son las personas que tienen
los recursos necesarios para migrar son
aquellos que pueden entablar un viaje
hacia las fronteras y poder salir del
país la gran mayoría del país tenemos
que recordar que un índice de desempleo
por ejemplo está cerca del 14 por ciento
no pueden emigrar no puede salir del
país y eso es lo preocupante el talibán
también tiene un gran riesgo que se
desarrollará una población que
históricamente ha sido empobrecida y ha
sido lanzada pues a una especie de
conflicto de atenciones latentes vamos a
ver si los talibanes van a poder hacer
esto y si lo van a contar con el apoyo
de algún país como por ejemplo china que
está muy interesado aunque esto insisto
no caiga en más violencia en las últimas
dos décadas